on va voir ce qu'il ya dans l'accord
parce que comme toujours quand un
partenaire comme la chine ouvre
davantage son marché
nous aussi nous faisons des concessions
et j'aimerais savoir lesquels on parle
d'énergie renouvelable j'ai quand même
un souvenir un petit peu amer de la
naïveté avec laquelle on a laissé
disparaître les entreprises européennes
en matière de panneaux solaires quand on
a commis une erreur une fois la répéter
c'est une faute
donc nous sommes le marché le plus
ouvert du monde
qu'avons nous à concéder qu avons-nous
concédé en terme de circulation des
travailleurs
je n'ai pas envie d'un porté sur le
territoire européen du dumping social
avec des travailleurs chinois qui
viendraient travailler à d'autres
conditions qui est travailleur européen
tout ça il faut être précis méthodique
ce n'est une par avance ni un oui ni non
mais c'est beaucoup de vigilance
[Musique]